how is Hillary 2016 just give me one
thing going to be different from 2008
well I think we've seen already that
it's going to be much more focused on
the Obama coalition if you look at her
video it was full of young people and
minorities gays and lesbians so she's
obviously trying to maintain the
coalition that got Obama elected twice
but I think what's most interesting is
that the whole style of her campaign is
different than last time around and she
seems to be pushing against the notion
that she is the inevitable nominee that
she's entitled in the nomination that
was basically her approach last time
around and as we all remember it ended
in disaster it did end in disaster and
of course no nomination Josh what about
though give me the juicy stuff what
about the infighting in her campaign in
2008 I mean weren't people like leaky
emails biting each other behind each
other's backs I mean how is she going to
change that around this time well this
is what I wrote about in Business Week
this week the irony is that last time
around Clinton made her main
qualification the idea that she could do
the job from day one that was the line
she used to say to take a kind of jab at
obama's and experience and the irony as
i write about is that she actually
proved to be a terrible chief executive
her campaign devolved into back back
fighting right different strategies and
the whole thing sort of collapsed so the
big question I think this time around is
will Clinton be able to function as an
effective as an effective executive for
her own campaign or when things get
tough will it kind of collapse again the
way it did last time and that's the one
big question I don't think anybody can
answer yet well didn't she hire John
Podesta to help stop that though well
she has taken a number of steps that
indicate that she gets what went wrong
last time she hired John Podesta a very
powerful respected Democrat right as her
campaign chairman and she also hired a
lot of veterans of the no drama Obama
campaign including her campaign manager
Robbie Mook but so far it's been smooth
sailing the only thing people are
writing about in the Hillary Clinton
campaign is what she ordered at chipotle
she hasn't encountered any real
resistance that would have put her
campaign under under pressure and tested
whether or not they can function in a
difficult environment
you give her credit for that Josh I mean
look she's the most watched and finding
a Chipotle well yeah I'd exactly for
like a you know being being an everyday
American Idiot row but they also be able
to give that element of surprise writing
she must be the most followed woman
around these days well you know she has
a lot of newer veteran Obama advisors
who understand social media they
understand the news cycle they know that
reporters like me a really tired of kind
of covering Hillary Clinton campaign
there were a little bit jaded and so
they need to do things to surprise us to
shake things up and I think obviously
the first you know five days have been
an example that they can do that we had
this like nationwide I don't know what
you want to call it manhunt to follow
her from gas station to chipotle to
whatever you know and we're writing
about that which I suppose is is better
and different than writing about what
water campaign is doing wrong but as I
say in the in the new issue of Business
Week I don't think we're going to know
really whether or not she's fixed her
problems until she runs into some kind
of meaningful competition and it looks
like that may not happen until next
summer when there's a Republican nominee
to go up against her okay and Josh
finally you know how does she leveraged
bill that's a great question i think i
think the biggest management challenge
of all is how do you manage Bill Clinton
because so far nobody has been able to
manage figure out a way to do it he was
a great help to President Obama in 2012
you remember you gave that wonderful
speech at the charlotte convention was
better frankly an obama speech but he
was a terrible detriment to Hillary last
time around he was bitter when she lost
he offended a lot of Democrats he
insulted Obama so she needs to figure
out a way to marshal him and sort of put
the good bill out on the trail and keep
the bad bill contained I think as I said
that's that's going to be the biggest
management channel love that good bill
bad bill I love that